how's it going my brows let's play some
more [ __ ] facade with this crazy ass
couple I don't even know what's wrong
with these people
I don't they just talk and I'm not
giving me headaches I don't even
um man let's just write talk and see we
get Kate okay
I don't want Kay that want [ __ ] I'm just
kidding okay it's with the background
music oh man oh man I'm Kate with a
really dark voice oh Jesus let me an
already um man Kate hey hi it's so great
to see you yes it's so great great give
me a hug
all right side yeah yeah you're the
world morning thanks
okay wow wow just wow just look at this
no now here we are this is beautiful wow
wow wow
hi how are you I am so happy to see
exercises along yeah that's been fred
has been a long time
just watched everyone hug you yes and
kiss you oh yes yes you like you like
when I kiss her you like that huh sweet
yes you like when it deal come on make
yourself at home
can I go in I kiss her I'll close the
door
yeah you're into that kind of stuff hmm
okay seeing you brings back wonderful
memories yes really
yeah I think we all know why I'm here
and I think I just realized up the
bullcrap
what quiet grab something we need to
celebrate quiet
I'm talking Jesus uh well listen to me
night is special yes
I'm here because so yeah I guess realize
ah Kate remember it was almost glad that
you introduced us
I'm talking here jeez God I'm here do
you remember yes we're gonna have a
menage tois
without you we wouldn't even have this
celebration so so do you want donut
maybe you can give me your yo where I
went wrong not decorating don't waste my
diamond look I'm giving her back killing
him you like do you like it baby woman
David you want the maniacally aah gasp
me do you not kiss me I kiss you like
fatback's what are you haunting me Kevin
give up hate when is evening is over you
know I spend a lot usually what you can
expect a racist you never know what may
be fine they call you from the neighbor
yeah oh man
efficient Oh Thunder and I keep getting
thrown out come on man
oh man no let's be alone for the couple
all right I think we know that I'll see
you next time
I just laughed you stop what are you
I'm late Viraj why is he going
yeah I want to go back he can't throw me
in to throw me out